bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge aujourd'hui
on vous propose de continuer une
découverte du patrimoine culinaire et
agricole de la réunion dans l'est à
saint benoît et plus précisément à bra
kanon
ici on va essayer d'en apprendre un peu
plus sur les fleurs de lys de la réunion
et les fruits ça se passe au comptoir de
médis a donc en compagnie de mélissa
c'est parti
le
son sommeil
m
mon dieu
comment ça va mais laissa pas tout à
fait donc moi je m'adapte à mélissa moi
je suis emmanuel excuse moi mais je joue
cool mais c'est quoi ces informations
que tim dunn pourquoi médicins alors là
mélissa et le nom du terrain sur lequel
nous sommes en fait quand quand on a
bâti d'exploitation à une des parcelles
s'appelait le terrain mélissa et au
moment de donner le nom à l'exploitation
d'un repris ce secret bon alors la
plantation s'appelle donc il est sa
plantation sainte anne qui est assez
assez large
tu fais tu plantes quoi ici alors ici
bas ici on fait des fleurs tropicales
c'est notre activité vraiment tout toute
l'année et puis au milieu des fleurs
tropicales on fait plein plein plein
plein plein de fruits banon sont
effectivement en plein milieu des fleurs
tropicales
c'est quoi par exemple 7 alors d'à côté
là on a les roses de porcelaine qui ont
des grandes grandes tiges avec des des
fleurs caché au milieu puis l'avait ça
c'est tout ce qu'on appelle les bec
d'oiseau a donc le le nom scientifique
étant les hélicos nyad je me sens un
petit peu comme alice au pays des
merveilles mois dans ce gigantesque
décor on est tous les titres qu'il
existe des fleurs tropicales endémiques
de la réunion où est-ce qu'elles ont
toutes été importés elles ont toutes été
apportées à la réunion c'est des
variétés qui sont plutôt originaire soit
des antilles soit 2 d'asie du sud est
une des caractéristiques des plantes
tropicales c'est que finalement une fois
qu'on les a coupés à ce concert
relativement bien et c'est ce qui fait
le fait qu'elle se alors là il ya un
petit secret il ya un petit secret mais
en fait c'est bref ça c'est pas tout à
fait des fleurs voilà donc ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle donc une tige de de fleurs
tropicales est en fait 7 7 6 à un
empilement de feuilles
on a des grandes feuilles vertes une à
droite une à gauche et quand on arrive
en fait au bout de la tige et bien on a
plus des grandes feuilles vertes
on a des feuilles colorées c'est parler
c'est pas les fleurs une fluence voilà
et la fleur alors je vais
et pencher tout ça et je vais essayer
d'attraper voilà c'est uniquement ça la
fleur de toute cette grande tige l'a
vraiment si j'ouvre ça pour que tout le
monde soit bien persuadés qu'il s'agit
bien d'une fleur voyez les pistils les
étamines est-ce que tu as une idée de
combien d'espèces différentes de forts
profits call combien il existe ici ici
ici à peu près une centaine mais qui
vont pas donner toute l'année il est
organisé par contre des visites pour les
clients tout au long de l'année voilà
tout confondre on peut même venez
impunément presse que plusieurs fois par
an on verra pas le sait qu on va pas
même par exemple les roses de porcelaine
là on est on est en hiver on va dire
c'est moyennement fourni quand même le
champ vous venez en plein été en plein
mois de décembre janvier
il n'y a plus de tirs avec des fleurs
que d'utiliser avec des feuilles
je
mais
quand
alors des fleurs certes mais sur ton
exploitation qu'est ce que tu fais
pousser d'autres alors à côté des
flammes on va voir plein de fruits en
fait à commencer par les letchis
c'est vrai que quand quand nous on a
repris l'exploitation
même si on a donné la priorité aux
fleurs il a toujours été question quand
même de garder le grand vergers de
letchis qui existait quand même voilà
qu'à une grosse dizaine d'hectares on va
dire et qui datent de donc dû du
grand-père de l'époque du grand père
donc dans les années 50 en fait c'est
quand puis il a acheté les terrains de
l'exploitation
la première chose qu'il a fait c'était
de chanter ce verdict je pense que c'est
possible d'aller sur plage de temps
plein allons-y
allez c'est parti
donc je ne pense pas me tromper en
disant qu'on vient d'arriver dans le
coin à lecci voilà il y en a mais c'est
pas encore la période visiblement
essayer de capter ça avec m mon ancêtre
de l'amour c'est vrai qu'en général
personne ne fait attention aux fleurs de
letchis parce que c'est assez
insignifiant ben c'est sûr que pour un
bouquet de fleurs il en faudrait une
certaine quantité là on voit les
premières fleurs les sont en train de
sortir
donc ça c'est des fleurs mâles et qui en
fait pour nous sont le le signal
d'installation des abeilles dans le
verger donc la bonne nouvelle
voilà plusieurs apiculteurs qui vont
venir mettre leurs ruches à différents
endroits du verger en fait le litchi
noms commencent sur le haut du rempart
on descend en fait on a toute une partie
qui est vraiment dans le rempart donc
pas très facile à accueillir dans notre
parti qui est dans le lit de la rivière
que la partie la plus ancienne de 10
hectares de letchis qu'est-ce qu'on a
d'autres
alors à côté des filles on fait aussi on
a des petits carreaux de banane on a une
autre grosse production qui est la
carambole les sa boutique on verra tout
à l'heure on a des sabots noir là c'est
aussi la saison en ce moment on a du
fruit à pain on a dû jacques la papaye
et concernant ton vergers pour pour ce
qui des fruits du coup pour la partie
fruits c'est pareil ça fait partie de la
visite que tu proposes au tfc aux
touristes aux écoles il t'arrive
d'organiser des événements aussi on fait
alors on a des petits ateliers à une
fois par mois on fait on fait un
un atelier de cuisine après il faut
aussi des cours d'art floral aussi de
temps en temps
et moi je suis assez tenté par la télé
confiture est ce que tu as à la proposer
aux l'a pas encore organisés mais pour
toi on peut le faire
allez c'est parti
eh bien nous arrivons là dans le verger
de sa boutique
le sympathique courant sol c'est la même
chose c'est la même selon eux mêmes
faits eux mêmes c'est le même fruit ça
petit c'est le nom qu'on va donner dans
l'est et le nord de l'île on va dire
dans les autres parties de l'île je suis
même pas sûr qu on appelle ça comme ça
et pour être sûr que je vais pour
récupérer un trop incident alors déjà
ils ont une certaine taille même bon là
c'est vrai que comme on est en hiver il
m'a par exemple on est sur le trop petit
en taille m p tit et puis surtout il est
beaucoup trop vert je crois qu'on a un
bon candidat juste la hâte en challenge
précise c'est pas comme ça qu'on ramasse
vesa petit normalement on accueille free
d'accord on se passe sur les armes comme
ce doit donc celui là voilà encore
quelques jours avant qu'il soit avant
qu'il commence à vraiment devenir moon
mur et quand il est mûr il est vraiment
très beau est ce que tend à instaurer
déjà récolté à quelques jours oui c'est
à la confiture commence à être un peu
chargé en ce que tu va me prendre ça
c'est parti
eh bien nous voilà donc arriver à
l'atelier d'accord alors d'abord je te
présente et isabelle bonjour usa hummer
et saab il met deux expertes confitures
et puis on va d'abord s'équiper
il nous faut une à tablier je veux que
je te déconseille de rire trop vite voir
mon ami parce que j'ai pour toi parce
que c'est pas parce que tu et chameyrat
main que tu veut échapper à la taxe bien
longue
aulas vial voilà donc arriver dans
l'atelier bella on a mis de côté donc
des corps au sol ça petit de plus plus
mûrs ont été ramassés il ya plusieurs
jours déjà et qui est bien quand on tâte
se sont beaucoup plus mou plus ce qu on
avait ramassé
non seulement c'est pas du tout la même
consistance à une chair comme ça bien
bien blanches avec des pépins noir qui
évidemment ne se mange pas tu défends
uniquement confitures les décors tous
les bons c'est aussi en fruits frais ont
fait aussi du jus avec et pour l'heure
ce qui nous intéresse c'est la confiture
c'est la confiture voilà qui est en
train de chauffer donc dans une grande
marmite donc là le principe c'est qu'on
a fait un sirop et
et une fois que le sirop est bien chaud
on a ajouté nos fruits directement le
sirop c'est quoi qu'est ce que tu fais
pour préparer tension et siro c'est de
l'eau et du sucre et une fois qu'ils ont
atteint une certaine température là ont
juste les fruits de ce qui fait qu'ils
vont cuire très rapidement et garder le
goût du oui alors coupé du corps au sol
il faut prendre ces lois on va me
demander de rembourser la luxair et du
coup après un certain temps de cuisson
quand même temps de cuisson au larnack
hui à peu près une petite quinzaine de
minutes mais c'est pas vraiment faim on
n'a pas un temps défini à nous c'est
vraiment on va on va regarder
à la consistance en fait si la confiture
et qu'on a alors produit quasiment finie
on n'a plus quelques ondées semaine il
faut le conditionner juste mettre le
produit bien bien chaud à l'intérieur on
ferme et le pot est prêt à les prêts à
être embarqués à la maison pour un petit
déjeuner avec les refroidit et presque
la sas et d'ustensiles en fait qui nous
sert à mesurer le taux de sucre ça
s'appelle un réfractomètre on va mettre
sur cette surface là un peu de jus en
fait de notre de notre préparation
tu te mets face à la lumière et tu vas
voir en fait dans cette dans cet objet
ah oui d'accord ok voilà il ya une
graduation et c'est là qu'on mesure 55%
donc du coup on sakho 5
on est vraiment voilà une nous confie tu
fasses ça peut commencer à s'appeler une
confiture ce qu'on a 50 1% de taux de
sucre dans la préparation
alors le fait que tu utilises ce type
d'outil ça témoigne quand même de
l'aspect professionnel que tu as voulu
apporter à la production c'est à dire
que on est sur des fruits locaux mais
dans la cour dans la fabrication on est
quand même sur dieu je sais pas parce
que c'est artisanal que le client ne va
pas attendre que d'une fois à l'autre on
est quand même la même recette et le
même goût au bout quoi c'est quand même
des pulpes qui sont faits entièrement à
la main j'ai déjà les virées puis la
confiture et et mélanger aussi à la main
telos au dollar donc après l'effort le
réconfort moi j'adore les journées comme
ça qui se termine autour d'une table
avec tout un tas de choses on a couvert
la neige est bien on a un goûter comme
ce qu'on propose à tous nos visiteurs un
petit banane blanche on a de la papaye
on à l'ananas
elle présente plus et puis on a de la sa
peau noire et on a et des confitures et
du jus le ca petit et donc après avoir
fait la confiture on va déguster le jeu
le juge a donc sauté propose d'écouter
en me renseignant un petit peu sur sur
son exploitation j'ai vu qu'elle existe
depuis maintenant depuis 1950
voilà depuis des années les années 50
alors nous on est arrivé en 2000 2002 et
quoi en septembre 2000 a en fait ben on
était en métropole donc j'étais plutôt
dans l'informatique et moi j'étais
ingénieur en électrochimie il est déjà
venu à la réunion
ah oui venu en vacances on a repris une
exploitation entre amis à la ville de
pau là pour le coup elle met le le
projet a été murée quand même pas mal
d'années parce que lui c'était quand
même son rêve d'enfant devenir reprendre
ici et en ce qui concerne le projet
depuis un an un an et demi on s'est
lancé dans la zec d'autres avec d'autres
agriculteurs dans la culture de cacao on
a créé une association
l'association des cacaoculteurs de la
réunion on espère développer développer
tout ça et puis obtenir un produit un
produit de très grande qualité qui va
pouvoir encore mettre en avant un savoir
faire local macoutes je suis très pressé
tu en as il va conclure ce projet je
repasserai à l'occasion mais d'ici là je
vais devoir te laisser ses lequel tu m'a
dit qu'il fallait que et là ça que j'ai
vite si je voulais avoir des droits mais
c'est cela oui ok allégé de faire la
bise je te remercie pour tous et à très
vite
merci à tous les vents
c'est comme ça que se termine ce nouvel
épisode alors vous l'aurez compris que
vous soyez botanistes amateurs ou
simplement gourmands je vous donne
l'adresse c'est le comptoir mélissa à
saint benoît en ce qui nous concerne on
se retrouve très vite sur les routes de
la réunion à raleigh a plus
une